there was miscommunication that we
didn't have clear on our part
Ottawa Arnhem as far as I'm you and
jasmine being here and maybe is my
misunderstanding or whatever wasn't
explained to me right
but you and jasmine you know can't live
here together you know under the same
roof but Sakhalin together absolutely
not
we're not having that you already know
how we feel about is for us religion is
concerned and in a Christian family
that's not what you do that's what not
what we do
yeah jasmine it's nothing no personal
against you you know she can be here as
long as she wants we welcome her and
with no problem but together that's not
acceptable to us in our beliefs and and
that's how we would like it for it to be
you understand yeah I understand ever
what was the miscommunication as because
like I didn't understand that you were
moving in and jasmine was moving in
Blake didn't clarify that exactly that
that you would like for both of you to
be moving since how we do things and you
know that that was like the whole reason
for you know coming out that's just
unacceptable
certain things that you know we believe
in that we just don't want you know to
have up under going on in you know so
that was like part of the plans but that
was that was your plan you and her
together here not acceptable
[Music]